Now let's do an ROB Timing quiz. So
here is again a sequence of instructions and we want to know when they issue,
execute, write, and commit. And we want some comments here.
Now let's say that an add takes one cycle, multiplication takes two cycles, and
divide takes four cycles. And in this processor, we can broadcast one add or
subtract result from the add subtract unit. And
one multiplication divide result per cycle. So if both the add unit and
the multiply unit have a result available they can actually broadcast them in
the same cycle. And this processor can also commit up to two instructions per
cycle. So two instructions can commit in a cycle if both of them can commit.
And we now free our reservation station at dispatch. So
let's look at what should be happening here.
We know that this instruction issues in cycle one. Begin execution in cycle two.
It will begin execution in cycle two. And then four cycles later in cycle six,
it's going to write the result. And it's going to commit in cycle seven. So
the question for you is for this multiplication. When does it issue execute,
write and commit? You can write your answers here.
So pretty much what should go here, you should write here, here, here and here.